[Musique]
haute forme et jupon étaient de sortie
dimanche dernier au Petit Moulin des
hautes Cernay le public était invité à
venir avec son propre pique-nique pour
vivre un moment convivial comme autant
des peintres paysagistes pour nous c'est
de faire connaître cette colonie de
peintre la colonie des peintres
paysagistes qui étaient installée ici au
19e et qui au 19e on peint notre vallée
et on suit lui rendre hommage parce que
l'âge d'or du pique-nique c'est
justement le 19e siècle la fin du la fin
du 19e c'est l'âge d'or du pique-nique
pourquoi parce que les gens souvent
n'avaient pas les moyens d'aller dans
les auberges etc manger donc il venait
directement ici avec leur Fricotin et
puis venez s'installer sur l'herbe et
manger en famille donc si vous voulez
pour nous c'est un retour en arrière
programme de cette journée bucolique des
cours de peinture des démonstrations
mais aussi des pièces de théâtre en
pleine nature notamment sur une peintre
célèbre qui est né dans les Yvelines à
maniyamo mais je vous dois de vous
verbaliser monsieur pardon madame quel
grand malaise fait alors là je viens de
jouer la scène de Rosa Bonheur qui était
une pinte du 19e siècle elle peint en
pleine nature et le elle est en colère
parce que on doit toujours elle doit
toujours se justifier de pourquoi elle
porte le pantalon d'autre peintre était
représenté tels que Claude Monet ou Léon
Germain pelouse qui a d'ailleurs sa
statue dans la forêt de Cernay-la-Ville
mais aussi un grand auteur du XIXe
siècle alors il faut savoir que Guy de
Maupassant est venu à pied il a parcouru
près de 60 km
dans la vallée de Chevreuse et il a
vraiment eu un coup de cœur pour cette
vallée et il a écrit à sa mère l'être à
sa mère qui est vraiment le détail de sa
journée de sa longue marche depuis 5
heures du matin jusque tard le soir
[Musique]
une journée qui est invitait à la flan
nerie peindre
le des Hauts de Cernay vraiment super
pour moi c'était la première fois que je
assistais à ça j'ai vraiment beaucoup
aimé te rendre hommage à cette façon de
vivre de cette époque là ça m'aurait ça
me paraît important voiture d'époque
ancien lavoir outils agricole tout était
réuni pour retourner au temps du 19e
siècle
[Musique]